Let's review a little bit of
what we've learned about
reserve banking and then we'll
extend this to the notion of
an elastic money supplier, a
money supplier that can grow
or contract as people need
money-- or hopefully grows and
contracts as people
need money.
So let me create a a couple of
normal commercial banks.
Maybe I'll call these
national banks.
They have a national charter.
So let's see.
I have some equity and part of
that equity-- most of it is
some gold that I initially
capitalized the bank with.
And then some of it
is a building.
Trying to draw this as neat as
possible, but I think you
understand my situation.
Then I take some gold deposits
from whoever-- the farmers
after the crop has
been harvested.
And then offsetting that,
I have all of
the farmers' deposits.
I'll do that in a blue color.
So that's one farmer's
deposit.
That's another-- maybe there's
only two farmers.
And then we learned in
fractional reserve banking
that I can leverage up this
amount of capital I have.
There's a certain ratio
between the amount of
capital-- in this case, gold or
reserves I have-- and the
amount of demand deposits I
can have. So let's say my
reserve requirement in this
world is-- just because I
don't want this bank to become
too tall-- let's say it's 50%.
We know in reality reserve
requirements
are more like 10%.
Let me write that down.
So that means that my ratio
of gold to demand deposit
accounts cannot be any
less than 50%.
So whatever this amount is, I
can double it in terms of
demand deposit accounts and the
way I do that-- let's say
this is collectively 100 so
I could have up to 100.
Let's say this right
here, this is 50.
So I can have up to 200 in
demand deposit accounts.
So I can essentially lend out
money and create demand
deposit accounts.
This is all review for
you, hopefully.
So I could lend out 150.
Those are my liabilities and
then these are my loans and
my-- so that's one loan I make
out and I just create
someone's checking account.
That's the loan asset and I
create a demand deposit
account for them.
That's the liability.
This here could be a big
loan, et cetera.
And then I'm not the only
bank in this universe.
My other bank in the universe.
I just want to show you that
there are multiple banks.
Then we said there are a couple
of issues with this.
You have a 50% reserve
requirement, which is very
high, but what if there is a
situation where for whatever
reason your reserves
temporarily
drop below that 50%?
How do you get that
extra gold?
You don't want to go to people
and say, can I have a little
bit more gold?
Then they're going to get scared
and all pull out of
your system, but if you're a
little bit below 50%, but if
the other bank is a little
bit above 50%, it'd be a
convenient way if you could
borrow from that other bank--
or even better, if there was a
central depository where all
of these gold reserves were,
then you could just borrow
directly from that central
depository if there were no
other bank to borrow from.
So you could kind of view it as
a lender of last resort and
we'll go into more of the
technicalities of that one, in
particular talk about
our current system.
With that said, we created a
reserve bank where we put
these deposits.
Let's see.
There's 200 of deposits
in this world.
Let see me if I can just
copy and paste that.
So that's one of the reserves
and then they're the same, so
then that's the other reserve.
It doesn't look that neat.
All the banks got together
and created this.
It's a private bank, but we'll
go into more details of of how
the actual Federal
Reserve works.
So those are the actual
gold reserves.
Those are the assets
of that bank.
Actually, I should move
it over some.
OK.
And then the liabilities for
this central reserve bank,
these are the demand deposit
accounts for these nationally
chartered banks.
So he took all of his gold,
put it here, and so now he
has-- to simplify it, he has a
demand deposit account, but
I'll assume that he just got
reserve notes to show that he
had access to this gold.
So let's say that this is
100 notes outstanding.
This part corresponding to 100
gold pieces-- and this is
another 100-- although notes
outstanding, it's fungible,
you could mix them up because
you don't know where they came
from or whatever.
That's what's different
about those relative
to a checking account.
And so essentially this guy
gives his gold here and in
exchange he gets these Federal
Reserve notes, which are like
green pieces of paper.
And now these are actually
his reserves.
His reserves are
no longer gold.
His reserves are how much
of these Federal
Reserve notes he has?
And we learned in the last video
that only the Federal
Reserve-- or the reserve bank--
I haven't called it the
Federal Reserve yet, but I think
you see where this is
going-- only they can
issue these notes.
And these notes are these
rectangular green pieces of
paper with faces of presidents
on them, et cetera, et cetera.
And let's say in the government
we live in, they
kind of sanction-- even though
this is officially a private
bank, this reserve bank, it's
set up in such a way that even
though all of the original banks
might have originally
capitalized it with some equity,
they really don't get
any of the profits of this
bank-- and I'll go into detail
on how the actual Federal
Reserve works.
But let's just say any surplus
profits of this bank actually
just go back to the Federal
government.
So the Federal government
doesn't-- these banks don't
make any money off of this--
and actually let's say that
the board of directors of this
bank is actually appointed by
the government, et cetera,
et cetera.
So it's key to the
financial system.
So the government says, these
notes, sure, it's issued by
this reserve bank, but we want
people to have a lot of faith
in this currency because this is
the currency that we use in
our world, in our nation, so
in order for people to have
unlimited faith in this
currency, we are going to make
it an obligation of the
government-- so it's
issued by the bank.
Let me write that down.
This used to confuse
me to no end.
Issued by the reserve bank, but
it's an obligation of the
government.
Now, what does that mean?
Well, that means that if for
whatever reason-- even if this
reserve bank were to somehow not
have the gold to back it
up, it would go bankrupt, but
even in that situation, the
government would still be
obligated to give you the gold
equivalent of these notes,
whatever we decide it is.
Maybe it's 35 of these dollars
per ounce of gold or whatever.
But that's what that means.
So that gives a lot of people
confidence that these things
are, you can almost say,
as good as gold.
Why does it matter that the
government-- how can you trust
the government?
Well, the government can just
tax people, whether they're
going to tax them in terms of
dollars, whether they can tax
them in terms of gold, whether
they can tax them in terms of
goods and services.
So as long as you think that
that economy-- whatever the
economy is that this government
is governing over--
as long as you think that that
economy can somehow support
the gold to back this up, you
should say, this is as good as
gold-- or at least support
the goods and services.
Well, that said, let's introduce
the notion of an
elastic currency.
Actually before I do that, let's
go back to one thing
this government does.
So we said it's an obligation
of the government, right?
Which means if all else fails,
the government is going to
give you the value behind
these notes.
I'll introduce you to another
concept, which is actually
very similar to these notes--
and that is a government debt
or government borrowing.
Let me draw that down here.
I think I'm going to run out of
time, but I'll continue it
in the next video.
So I'm the government, right?
I mean, you could almost view
the government's asset as its
ability to tax people, but if
I'm the government and I issue
these government IOUs-- and
we'll call them treasury bonds
and bills-- let's call them
treasuries, generally.
Treasury bills are short term
treasuries where the
government borrows for a
shorter amount of time.
Bonds are longer term.
I think I've gone over that in
the yield curve video, but
I'll do that in more detail.
But they're just IOUs
from the government.
Now, these are going to be
considered as risk free.
Why are they considered
risk free?
Because they are denominated in
the same currency that the
government, that the economy
that this government governs
over, operates in.
So if this government-- and I
think you can understand that
this is essentially the U.S.
government-- if it borrows
money from you-- so it
gives you an IOU.
So this is me.
Let's say this is me, this
is the government.
If it gives me this IOU and I
give it $100, why do I know
that this IOU is risk free?
Well, because unless he starts--
the government-- I'm
making him masculine-- but
unless they start issuing an
unusual number of IOUs and just
have so much interest
that they can't sustain, you
know that they can always tax
more people to get you
back your $100.
So you view this thing right
here as risk free.
So whenever the government goes
out there and says, hey
everyone, we have a new war we
want to fight or some new type
of scheme, new bureaucracy we
would like to create, we are
going to borrow money from you--
someone is going to give
them their currency, their
Federal Reserve notes-- and in
exchange, the government's
going to give them
these risk free IOUs.
And then the government can use
these reserve notes to go
buy goods and services or
pay soldiers or pay the
bureaucrats.
Now we're going to use that
idea in the next video to
learn how this Federal Reserve
bank or this reserve bank can
buy and sell these government
securities in order to change
the money supply.
See you in the next video.